stephanie is a single mom who has just
told us about her debt-free story and we
thought it would be fun for you guys to
hear
and this is Victoria and Victoria how
old are you sighs you're beautiful are
you married yet are you married yet
no silly old man
okay mr. Stephanie how much debt did you
pay off $66,000
how long did that take 44 months three
and a half-ish years and your average
income or your range of income during
that time thirty-six to 70s 80s towards
the end wait a minute how do you double
your income because what do you do for a
living I am a registered nurse so you
didn't tell me so I'm gonna guess when
you start getting out of debt you took
on a bunch more hours they knew who to
call to work day or night great place to
go when you're broke to work yeah so who
watch Victoria I have a village of
people that watch Victoria and some of
them are here today but my mother other
single mothers my mom other single
mothers the church village her dad so we
just had like a village of people that
kind of took turns my sister as well
what kind of debt was a 64 thousand most
of it was student loans from Baylor
University I'm a student athlete so my
first degree I was free because I paid
for it through sports would you play
basketball and volleyball Oh
a Baylor bear alright and you play
volleyball too I'll bet I'll bet you're
good at it
very cool so what puts you on this
journey to get out of debt 44 months ago
Baylor University when we graduated they
op they showed us your video the debt
free part of your class and the older
one and that started my mind thinking I
continue to watch the rest of the
classes and then I found financial peace
at Preston Christ Church of Christ and I
took that and that just lit the fire
what was the hardest part of the last 44
months that's a long time um one time
when I worked up and that's it how about
it tell her good night what [ __ ] come
home and be with me mom mom I want you
to come home and be with me and you were
working sweetie hi Victoria have you
been practicing your debt free scream
because your mama has paid a price to
change your life all right you ready all
right Victoria and Stephanie $64,000
paid off 44 months count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
Wow